Brendan's starting this podcast out
having stuffed his mouth with the cab
rack I took a girl to me this one time
she was I feel eggy
well you gotta get out that's so
disgusting it's so disgusting and my
boner went you know what I'm out that's
a disaster and just remind me cuz out of
carry I almost said I feel egg you know
eggy like my brain went let's let's go
throwback Thursday that time you almost
threw up in your mouth when that [ __ ]
said I feel eggy before you guys are
gonna have sex altercations have you
ever been in a gym well I was in a very
quiet hotel gym lie and I was want to
work out okay and is this this weekend
uh-huh and guy comes down and goes do
you go I just go
he's stretching right and did he say I
feel a medium II feel me I feel me do it
I feel me he starts working rounded yeah
yeah I'm feeling real me you know what I
feel me D gonna pull out peel your dong
I'm feeling me this watch he bow yeah
that's the noise you make this guy was
working out of he was doing this he was
he doing work done no [ __ ] no he's on
the machine thing I was like distant I
will down the throat for [ __ ] that's
right headphones I got right now I was
just like [ __ ] this it's my [ __ ] her
headphones dude what are you doing dude
I don't want you to make sex with shape
though no no he was at he had a long
yoga body he had super short legs it
[ __ ] penguin he was a man penguin
with the longest tour salutely black guy
right no no white a [ __ ] yeah no [ __ ]
obviously yeah I'm not a black guy just
like [ __ ] I was like you're how do
you have first of all use like six four
and he had legs that belonged on summary
judgment
that way judges guy trying to get better
dude I know man I got to give love
something it looks like your Corgi heat
would hit the body of your Corgi with
some man Corgi the main course [ __ ]
man Gorga - got him out there first went
I feel me you know what I can is there a
machine for this yeah and just pull out
my three pieces now I guess suck I feel
media is there is there a sock machine
God you could do that with your boys at
the club sigh God fellas I feel meaty
well get sucked feel like that's gonna
catch on so disgusting that could be a
shirt I feel me well my next bastion
have a glow that's a girl feel me I feel
media just made me D starring Bryan
count chin would you ever sail around
your boys like guys let's go get your
[ __ ] Korean barbecue and get suck
that feel meaty no yeah you say that
every [ __ ] day you mean maybe a green
barbecue you could say a Korean barbecue
man I feel meat puppets let's go get
some [ __ ] meat because we feel meaty
you and I cat went out this weekend got
food without us how about that what the
[ __ ] we even talked about you guys even
mention it and going like yeah like
you're ever gonna go to cream bar we
would 100% never we're no first sure
just call me I want to answer but you
get what you guys went to grand barbecue
just the two of you hmm
how I mean Jo time I was cuz I saw the
picture when I was in DC backstage how
did that even get started who Tex who
here I'm assuming cat Tex chin know what
happen text a cat yeah we actually
talked in person about it oh and you
were like hey which go you korean
barbecue yeah
and then you said this weekend yeah
that's how people meet up I just find it
fascinating I don't know why me and Jay
were trying to figure out who invited
who it would make sense you'd be friends
up because you're around each other yeah
we're sure time are you pregnant yet
fantastic the kids heads on eBay at all
coming out yeah you won't need a
c-section at all was where'd you guys go
quarters the place to talk about all the
time with cheese oh yeah good as you
thought cat it's good I've been there
before
not great though it's good mmm expensive
it's a little pricey
who paid chin would not let me pay oh I
oh I thought your split it I was gonna
kick you in the nuts for the first time
chin Chin's awesome okay thanks thanks
guys he also didn't make me cook the
meat yeah you would let her keep that's
traditional in the 19th on top talk
about this what's the meat culture here
you can I mean if your meaty Koreans
yeah and there's there's Korean girls
yeah the girls usually take care of the
guys oh they do yeah I like this I like
these even more okay hold on show you
like hell no it's June 19 I'm gonna take
care of you exactly no we had there
you're a Korean feminist dude yeah your
Korean shut up they cook for you there
luckily so okay we're good it's also is
where the waiters will cook for you
that's my meat if we were a couple real
meaty out of [ __ ] cook of course
hey hold on are you don't waitress it up
but the waiter stood there and cooked
you're mean they don't stand there they
kind of like do a little you know
turnover this turnover that what a
nightmare and they walk away and they
hang around and come back they come back
you never been there Korean barbecue
yeah I have but I don't want to hang
around cooking my meat the fun is doing
yourself yeah you could just do that if
you want you cook it yourself you turn
it over if you want because you want to
eat it I don't want that homeboy I don't
want that now I want to go to Korean
barbecue right this planet I wish I
haven't eaten much no no I'm into
intermittent fasting now I brought what
a video yeah you look the same
my face is [ __ ] old you're here you
walked in nightmare I cut it myself
I gotta get it's not that it's just not
that why trying to cut the back and it
seems a little dude we missed you in DC
man yeah I loved you they love you in
Philly I love ya you got a do feel I'm
gonna
he Lampton school club it's very
scheduled now for anyone I'm gonna
you're gonna absolutely love it yeah my
boy who runs that show you rent Brandon
right manager Brandon is the manager and
will be your handler terrible news yeah
but he's he's got Philly lockdown oh
yeah
you understand me here with some Philly
cheesesteaks hey and can he get me give
me skinny salvages meaty
hey listen me right now yeah he's if you
feelin me you can take my context you
didn't meet Brandon gotcha Brandon I
think I know I'm coming like a few
months Brandon I feel I'm gonna give you
heads up now yeah feelin me feelin me
gonna be in Philly
yep I hate talking about cheesesteak
uh-huh yeah Brent and I I brought my boy
Herman rice who's an up-and-coming comic
agent black six foot six just off yep
you're off Herman rice rice Herman rice
wri ce-1 my twice
Oh fantastic dude Weiss Weiss who writes
Lynn yww silent okay and he's got roots
in Philly okay this is a guy from Philly
guys in like only got it easy al he
lives in LA yeah listen LA and you flew
him to fill it I flew him in a fool he
flew any because he got so much family
there and but I said you know all we see
you around the store anything you you
don't you do you'll see him I'll
introduce you set the relevant sets he
does sets at the improv but he's like a
new comic oh yeah he was working at the
Emperor I knew him cuz he worked the
door at the improv okay and he's just a
stray went up to him cuz big black guy
but no a basketball lady one ball four
years at South snow but never taught
side that in full no God no because he
said to me hey man do you have any
reading recommendations cuz I think he
had to listen to the podcast or he had
seen my stand I mean he goes do you have
any reading recommendations I'm trying
to and I was like - I
that's the warranty and ask me how do I
do it real quick basketball player and
then you guys went on I said yes I do
young man didn't know that he doesn't
come off that way he just six black guy
just that you just don't been around you
enough final love is like when you're
around him and you'd be like but but
then later on I was like we were talking
and he said I said were you an athlete
it goes yeah yeah I played do you want
so he sews and were like oh I'm going to
Philly Steve didn't go Stevie couldn't
go so so I'm on there
and he's got his family he's got his
extended family his friends and when his
mom is six five
his dad is six five Jesus his brother
six nine to be everybody in that family
like Great Danes I I looked like I had
been and they would be all in the green
room and I looked like I had you I'd
been one in a car could you not take a
picture like I did I have a picture of
all you surrounded by them yes
Herman's I mean chin yes it's probably
on Herman Rice's Instagram by the way it
was it was great and it was you have a
Philly cheesesteak I did not have a
Philly cheese well what are you doing I
know but I love to spot walk around
Philly man I can't wait to you go
because you're gonna walk for you go to
old city did I've been there bro we're
together watch what he says when a
second third by the second that's all
his voice that's just his friends that's
Donny who's six nine who's kneeling in
front that's his brother
Herman's guy the way back have you seen
Herman I've never seen him a bright guy
he's way more just a Fanta he's funny -
he's gonna be and do really well that's
him there
yeah that's who's like goofy your
picture that's the goofiest [ __ ] was a
kid on the right he's a comic a local
comic that guy Brian is really funny
he's a he's a local comic and Philly
very funny crushed it and he was my MC
this is oMG boy - so you had an emcee
feature the other one they were all like
this isn't no yeah he was just there but
either way it was a great it was
remember we did the truck Ghaderi taxis
a family that's mom that's dad that's
just pretty-looking people yeah
good-looking booty-licker and great
people do like her she's she's family
two cousins somewhere down the line I'm
not gone in there was a good Jean yep
then there's little bride now that guy
over there that little guy that's the
uncle I think he's the he looked like
the trouble uncle he looked like the
problem uncle he looked like a little
while yeah he looks like he's the guy
who didn't you look they're all they're
all such great people yeah um [ __ ]
great people did you uh remember last
time last time I was in Philly you and I
did the truck at Darrow and that place
closed down it closed down drug dealers
no no Sarah it's a bummer huh yeah
you're so
so helium isn't one of those what we
call an old-school club right well
there's a it's a chain there's a bunch
of them but this yeah but the building
it's helping around I think this is the
first one to ever bell rings so cool so
what you're gonna find is it - its they
pack it in low ceilings that's what you
want in a club that's the traditional
commune I with the corporate things big
ceilings that's how DC is yeah you get
those low ceilings where you just it's
just packed and you feel that energy
just it's beautiful and Philly you're
gonna walk around Philly you'll go to
old so you can go anywhere you want you
can walk anywhere and you'll go down to
old city and what you'll do is you'll
see old cities where the Constitution
was written where all those money we
don't have this brother I know we did
that's right
did we stand in line and wait for the
and see the Bell yeah remarried we wait
yeah Jay was with us he went it was my
pal yeah is amazing yeah
a bell with a crack man Phil I do love
Philly DC might be my favorite go City
man I love DC is he's fluffy and raised
it and the cherry blossoms or a boom in
they were yep they're a booming well
it's our nation's capital you know where
I went where you know where I went to
the comet ping-pong pizza where Pizza
Gate that I saw you said the picture to
me Eddie Bravo and Rogan and I think
Eddie said get the young meatlovers
supreme yeah and Rogan said bring your
son you get better service I'm at pizza
how was the pizza first of all so it's
in there like a a great area where a
bunch of politicians live okay and then
it's a Capitol Hill right yes so like
obviously like Obama the Clintons all
the all the big politicians eat there
why because it's great food not because
there's a child a sex ring that way to
eat so some of the best pizza ever had
the best chickens ever had on planet
Earth
amazing food yeah and so cameras with me
cuz they're shooting all-access leading
up to my special yeah so they're RIT and
I go well we got to go this place but I
did a bunch of research tonight before I
even talked to rogue you know like a now
this is true right he's like no it's not
[ __ ] of course
so I mean Jay did all this research and
stopped see all fake and kind of the
first fake news story with the women's
Jones that is [ __ ] so the guy who
shot up the place with ak-47 because
they said the Clintons were had a
children's sex trafficking ring in the
basement right well there's no
no basement well there's no basement
there's no pay so that the guy who came
with a automatic rifle and shot up the
play shot the closet where he thought
led to the basement
but it's closet yeah so he went away for
four years if he yeah the cop who
arrests him kid in my show too spoke to
him all about this but that's so cool
yes but you know what the cop told me
the idea was that guy either got out
he's getting out and even he says it's
fake he's like that's not real he's like
you know you definitely know it's not
real cos and then the me he's probably a
really dumb guy who's also a good guy
like he's so dumb that he was like I'm
gonna go save children nobody's doing it
if not me would any one's not now not
and then shot into the closet trying to
save kids so dumb good good but dumb
that's fair right good
but Thomas [ __ ] should they put you down
bobbly either way you're back on the
street - yeah so the managers there and
we have cameras right and they're like
absolutely not but we kind of got some
stuff and then we amazing food I go I
got a ask you man Pizza gate and he's
like an older dude and he goes uh I
guess you see it's like wearing ah yeah
how long you worked he goes from day one
man and he goes I've been close with the
owner because it's exhausting I go is
there any to that and then he just
started go like go this is where it
started it was the first kind of fake
news story that actually qinglai started
as a joke start as a joke but also then
it then it goes back to the government
in Turkey where there they actually had
issues with pedophilia and go so they
released they actually put effort into
this because they went back look at the
Americans doing it too and then it just
the weekend just went down swear spiral
we were just given food you know pizzas
to the Clinton campaign when they had
this and the kids and then they figured
all this stuff out he goes it's a night
if you want to really then you know I
said he goes businesses up it's never
business has never been higher bigger
like we're killing it it's packed good
and I said well the advance for you guys
is you have great food and he goes
that's how we got famous
you got great food politicians eat here
we just make good food where did you
stay what hotel the Dupont Circle Hotel
okay go to hotel great hotel really yeah
that's where I should say yeah III don't
have any plans to go to DC and I have
TCM proms great yeah but yeah I almost
felt bad for the guy then a few months
ago there someone tried lighting the
place on fire cuz they think it's an
establishment that does sex trafficking
and the you tell the guy was so over it
and then I go man if your business boom
and why not just market the [ __ ] out of
it create like a pizza gate shirt I have
like a tinfoil hat on piece of pizza not
how no no no what do you want say
anyways I I'm gonna get your building no
doubt no doubt yeah nothing came back
and gave me t-shirts ah that's great I
was gonna wear nobody wants nobody wants
to be no tributed to a child porn
especially here legit place yeah here's
the thing bein that I was telling chin
about this here's the thing me and Jay
are talking about this even knowing all
that going in I like do we really want
to film there like this is weird you
know all that I get in and I well it's
almost it's a hundred percent not know
that's true it's fake news it's come out
faking of course the shooter stones fake
news alex jones for fucksakes
you guys is lord and savior cents fake
news out jones so he know and all that
doing all the research knowing no that's
not real I walked in and still was the
kind of like a heavy fee that's what
happed it's like oh the way you do what
the guy told me goes you you want me to
show you where the basement is I what he
goes there's no basement yeah I would
use that here's you wanna walk the rent
what do you want to do what's gonna make
you feel better like oh I'm so sorry man
that's not that's not what I mean they
felt like she oldest the oldest just
always remember that the way they would
always justify getting a mob to kill a
group you didn't like almost always the
Jews by the way is you would spread
rumors about how JEWS drink blood that
was a big one the child's blood they
steal boy killed Hren
they steal non-jewish children drink
their blood that was a big one when the
Jews didn't die as much from the bubonic
plague because they covered their Wells
and they washed a lot yet cetera et
cetera they were playing for starting
the plague
there's there's there is story after
story so much of this [ __ ] has its roots
and all of that and if you picked up a
history book which [ __ ] dummies never
do read the comic let's turn you and so
can you realize not many of them have
read a conspiracy no parity period could
kill
that's the problem if you're gonna have
a conspiracy there are some conspiracies
I'm a real please be yeah but please be
informed and what you're doing is it's a
way of demonizing a group of people it's
one thing I'm not I don't like the I'm
not a big left-wing guy okay I got my
problems with with [ __ ] I have huge
problems with socialism we can go but
you should call Billy Corbin right but
don't don't like don't start calling the
Democratic Party they don't they don't
drink child's blood and they don't know
here's the problem
today's the news like you're not the
Russians are involved there's no
credible sources because now any news is
real news we can't decide you know they
think you know that Russia Russian then
this was just on Rogan and on Sam Harris
Russia has a take advantage of spreading
anti-vaccine propaganda direct this stop
this stuff breaks it they think Briggs
and here's a problem here's the problem
is we give grounds to it we give it its
launch of pegs we go there might be
something in Russia goes look at these
morons exactly do exactly look at these
it's called confirmation bias if you
feel something you're gonna look for
anything that that compounds that
feeling instead of looking at real
evidence you follow the food was
fantastic game II sure it's a Buster
Jason the staff Jay we all got shirts
how's it go I'm gonna wear it today you
got a you got a comment there Eddie
Bravo on Alex Jones are already in the
basement what does it say busting up a
satanic about he does i takes him off
our group text
I went dude any legit [ __ ] going on here
he goes the darkest story you've ever
heard no they got god dammit them I love
that yeah but you know please great food
don't eat great food I'm not be there
yeah I got a nominal fee honey I like
the look I like that green oh it's cool
sorry right there it's in there great
foods up no there are tons of kids
that's a good that's where it goes yeah
he's next to it's like you're chillin
Center there's ice cream shop next door
let's get food yeah great area man yeah
I love DC DC is great
yeah it's cool it's really good like
Randall Terry every everything you need
dude last night didn't my
patent it Sunday Sunday night in ritual
ordered a large pizza from Mahal ins
pizza shout out to them and then I
watched break it out now American Idol
yeah last night was three hours long
really there's nothing I want to watch
in this plant if I watch three Game of
Thrones back-to-back I'm not sick of it
by the third yeah three hours of
American Idol I don't give a [ __ ] this
is the problem some musicals solve too
much it's just simply what that Hamilton
is too long yeah hour-and-a-half on with
man I was great then it excuse me
there's another out affluent oh well I'm
out because I've seen it yeah mom I'm
done I want to move on you've heard it
three hours too much
three hours America I'll wait too much
they cut all the people sad stories the
kid who's two brothers commit suicide
this year see yes both it's a girl with
mothers commit suicide [ __ ] you didn't
show up great for the final audition so
they cut him stir the girl with one eye
who I keep telling about c1 IRA or no no
pun intended
Wow one eye the one whose wine the black
well you well yeah it's like one iced
fuzzy in them ones completely blind they
told her to kick rocks the black girl
yeah she's 17 you know what you got a
kick you got to be ruthless otherwise
American island means nothing that's
what they said they do one kid who I was
like man I like him and Lionel Richie
went he said something like you know at
first we can't tell for in to your
friend to the idea that you portray like
we don't know if you're if you're
talented enough to make this show and
they got him and then when I thought
about like [ __ ] they know what they're
doing of course it's like we are create
the top 20 the top 20 have to be the
best they get a bunch of people men and
they can all sing the ones they cut they
can all sing right seeing seeing some
woman so how about there's one kid this
redhead kid
badass straight as a [ __ ] you know
bowling ball super gay and he uh he
works for his family's Church he's a
janitor mopping the floors if he walked
in here right now room who off the bow
Joe oh he's clearly gay like it's like
he's on fire gay right the family finds
out on American Idol that he's gay cuz
he's like young gay
I haven't told my family I work at a
Christian Church the doubt fires him
he's like it might they kicked me out of
the house because I'm gay he's like
crying and he's still dedicating songs
of his family and [ __ ] they passed him
how stupid do you have to be if you're
that family man no I mean this is your
son's been gay from the judge you're
surprised he's just born with that list
son yeah come we see is there any way we
can see him that's really interesting
but I do like what I do like that they
that they you know they're that ruthless
it's it makes it no that's not local
sooner that's not it there's been a few
redheads go um cremaster sunk gay sob
past your gay son there is just a
Christian without to say Christian gay
son Darius there he is
so you look at that like let's hold her
long neck I guess is there I love Katy
Perry oh he can sing sing bro really
little volume here first of all the way
he waved did you see the way he waved
this thing's so obvious doing me hear
him sing right now I work as a janitor
at a church in Catonsville not anymore
Playboy yes it's actually my dad's
Church Katy Perry was a PK oh I know
that you repeat kids do i she grew up
strict Christian I hail from the Harmon
family hidden team that guy is mopping I
love this in the trash kid things easy I
felt a sense of their circuit that fix
sister though and there's certain parts
of she's a beautiful off
I first realized that I was gay when I
was nine years old I had a crush on the
guy and he's kill ya even night I feel
like it's a little late yeah and also
know your kids my parents right family
yeah
well stupid those are grown adults I'll
be like this is just a phase it's a sin
Brennan the hardest part see hey get
over at family how about so he makes the
to the final cut everyone else's family
they're his family doesn't come he's
still dedicated can I ask you a question
how much of this is staged how much of
this I would be tough man know how this
works right he's not gonna factor well
you got to see when you watch it really
like the kid who whose brothers commit
suicide oh my god that swine girlfriend
on stage that's horrific
I don't think this stuff is that stage I
think I do think American Idol prey
rolls with it and really harps it up but
I mean like this kids not good enough
because he gets off stage he's ball he's
almost arts crying on stage he's bawling
cuz he sings a song to spare let's go
ahead and hear this song real quick and
then we'll get out of here a place for
me and know this is over he's we stand
he plays a piano - most of them play you
can sing sing sing yes I think he wrote
this song - yeah this is his own song
I'm pretty sure yeah the course is good
just wait this I know this is bit
[ __ ]
[Music]
really laughter that cat he's again Jen
you're a singer ha
is he a little pitchy yeah a little
pitchy not perfect
Nia not perfect no no no boys you got to
be perfect right now
American Idol I'm telling me top 20 he's
not seeing as this well no I'm saying
but he got cut no he made it bro no he
got cut it eventually ultimately he got
eliminated right no oh he made it
I wasn't following that I thought you
said though he's top 20 in the world his
parents didn't show up and he still made
oh no oh yeah remember he's never sang
in front of a lot of people are like I
sing at home or like when they do the
live auditions when there's a full band
yeah the first time they've been on a
stage damn so Americanos oh [ __ ] you
have talent okay yeah okay Wow
all right that is so cool I got to watch
the show I'm pissed I don't watch this
funny I remind you every I don't even
watch my own show
he doesn't familiar so I enjoyed what a
great song oh that's that's the that's a
great song that's the song that he sings
that's AG be honest it I feel like them
doing it outdoors doesn't help them no
look at her she looks ridiculous that's
not about to those girls so true well
their family's missing out because
they're idiots
you count the Sun men
I love this song great song okay hey
Katie see he's not gonna factor for this
you're right buddy like you get does
really hurt like to grab those [ __ ]
pants by the throat
how stupid what God's will believe in
Peeta you know what there's no
difference in the outcast near Sonny's
and pizza gate so I'm trying the same
they're afraid that they might be gay
yeah and there's I don't think it's that
I think there's so balls deep into Jesus
yeah and they think that book is the
end-all be-all sure that there's so
narrow-minded yeah well even in 2019
yeah well anyway good stuff good stuff
I'm gonna have to that's too late you're
definitely I want to get an ad carry
Katie it isn't about you and please take
it easy boyfriend by the way hos well
they're sinners they're sodomized and
then they're both gonna hell yeah
and I hope you like your hot boys oh I
hope you like it hot hey guys hey guys
guess you just signed up for a hot tub
for the rest of eternity you too
guess you'll be sucking dick in the hot
tub yeah it's like their parents are
just can you imagine the world was made
of people like their parents it used to
be what the music they used to own their
end of all too beautiful
it used to be though I don't know what
that is right we pretend that never
happened carry on
it's like the Amish don't allow dancing
are really much singing I haven't heard
a whole lot of Amish music got it oh
they still around huh
aren't they the ones I can't use
electricity you're seeing walking yes
they've done things on military like
countries that that are kind of run by
the military where the military like
rules everything in that's left of us
and the music is always young done done
we'll just as we're yeah you need that
get a suck yeah then you need you need
your gentler spirits and sometimes
they're gay or they're weird or they're
different you know thank God
dude speaking a different check out my
[ __ ] kid - those are terrible now do
they come with transformer [ __ ] a
robot because
well no what are you wearing no you old
fun are you wearing this is the shape of
Mars and they have NASA inside and if
you take a picture there the moon I
don't understand Brendan you have
business socks on I don't expect you a
well I don't really appreciate those oh
you know who makes them Brendan ah small
company called Nike were they expensive
I don't know I don't see dollar sign at
price X it looks forward to me now house
will be in China
your wretched muscle being Chinese that
well let's not show my girls titties why
not
your girl's God she's something else
your son's no like your son's neck is
that's what my son took this picture by
the way so look and then put on the
flash girl the next boom we on the moon
baby
wow that's pretty impressed yeah you
like that [ __ ] Yeol [ __ ] no so you got
thought about Harry's yellow shoes what
I know those are different just three
pairs that be the same pair bro that I
took a picture of the camera filter
[ __ ] flat sided camera oh no easy
take it easy
don't be such an ageist younger okay man
Oh dope sneakers brah oh those are dope
sneakers bro Russell's Khalifa Wiz
Khalifa know where my Easy's at I'm kind
of better due to are you gonna get the
face thing done
I don't know I want to I'm getting the
old eyes talked up nip/tuck yeah
nip/tuck e tuck
you won't you some fashion plans to [ __ ]
you Vernon I think Michael avenatti got
his her lids done when I was looking at
him talk I said yeah go to prison growin
up you got your you got your eyelids
talked I don't know how you tell these
days I just can't tell ya I wouldn't
mind getting tits again see some
implants I think calves and then pecs
wouldn't 1 & 2
I have you get avenues jabs on if you
get AB implants do though see he should
be a shipping
more liddie oh you wish hater I think I
don't think he's done much a strong jaw
well cuz I'm good you need that strong
jaw yeah the prison for see his eyes I
think he got him done really sad there
would you ever get anything done cat
she's about 17 times well no you've who
started off on me for titties would you
do it she's got tits depends on how much
money cuz then I would have to be out of
work for extended time I mean that lets
say well we're not asking I would not
allow it but you will you'd be out for
some people's two days can't you do it
Friday titties are here on Monday
what you mean two days dicks that week
it's like six months no no not these
days really I'm you can't work out and
[ __ ] for about two months I think yeah
well you'll be able or the armpit
different ways you can put the implant
you pick they can even go through the
belly button now I think or something
crazy I don't know I think you just go
freaking I would imagine go I don't know
why you go all the way through the belly
button you go through the nose yeah good
then you throat um yeah nowadays maybe
like two weeks you're like up and Adam
would you do it probably not
realistically I'm too afraid of going
under the knife yeah anesthesia I like
the idea of it though you do like the
idea because yeah yeah I could talk you
know about having a part of your set I
can plants yeah I just come from a long
line of women with fake boobs you do
know I feel like yeah beat it yeah she's
got fake boobs or ants got fake why yes
I come from a generation of coffee shop
girls that's why but if you feel like
you're already you have a shot during
the the asian chicks and bikinis serving
coffee in Orange County that my aunt
owns one Wow I come from a line of
coffee shop women I love my cat and your
Olli [ __ ] risk of cream barbecue I take
a serious big tits are that your family
ones are not so what that's the type of
that's what I was supposed to be I think
if I didn't go to USC that's one
see that was our future yeah which
there's no issue with it
no I feel about this I mean I'm sure
your Vietnamese gals have booties no no
we have fake boobs but it is delicious
but I feel like you're living okay in
that area so why would you get fake you
know I mean I don't I don't know I just
like the idea yeah I don't think I
actually want them but the idea is
appealing right no way that girl in the
middle is just white the other ones
she's Mexican yeah now there are a lot
more white coffee shop girls some
Mexican coffee shop where are these
Coffee County stuff
on your way to Disneyland stop by Little
Saigon yeah and any we're gonna express
on a suck it's um binamis coffee which
is basically oh yes hard-core espresso
and condensed milk yes this weekend and
if aliens [ __ ] up hey if I don't want
that condensed milk you're my that ruins
everything if I don't want Jesus if I
don't want to go there get an orange
juice get a team are they are they
jacking the boys off in the back there's
probably some girls doing that but in
general that's frowned upon
well no but I can't my shot my Louise
coffee yeah I know I never have never in
my life I've never heard of this I guess
this is a Saigon a mini Saigon thank you
huh we could open one as though we could
you have all types oh you just have to
be Asian girls we open up to everybody
why don't we get into that one in LA cuz
they're all in Orange County nobody
wants to make that drive are they
illegal out here why are not in LA it's
just that's where all the Vietnamese
beauty that could be shy yes block rifle
with Drive the big brown / Brian can but
I want to be involved I want to be I
want to be an entrepreneur
big brown / Brian - can't have it made
off your shop hey brown / Bry guy - no
that's what all the time man that's a
real place I wanna manage it and and get
me - yeah alright just over and over
again
you alright alright ladies I'm feeling
meaty who's out
I feel meaty well it's Monday night it's
meaty Monday me it's meaty Monday and
guess what old bribry got the flare of
the psoriasis you got here so don't
touch don't touch my legs
I'm in a bikini started to pump in I'm
gonna bikini and and just psoriasis and
I'm serving coffee anybody feeling me
anybody wants to meet with their car
ladies get your espresso shots I'm
feeling meaty
yeah get fired for sure probably man
that is fascinating that's where he's
supposed to be like at mm-hmm that's
where I'm supposed to be all meat we saw
on your Instagram story sunset you money
for your feet no somebody found my venmo
work and then people I put it out just
to see how much money I would get people
started just giving me money and I just
thank them for helping me keep my feet
off of the Internet Wow
so I have not had to send any photos I
made like $250 that NIC guys are just
jacking off to the baby cool giver model
yeah what your feet on take a picture of
your feet and and charge I want to see
how much you make charge get it got an
adorable picture of your little feetsies
yeah $1,000 from a guy named big what
Zach and a close-up of your little
toesies call them anybody want to see my
little piggies some no don't call
piggies the guys are like that no no
what just cute name just take a picture
Fein put meow with a little emoji of a
cat and [ __ ] dolls you and for you it
please i want to see how much you make I
will set it up where would you post a
picture at 2:00 for them to see it to
pay chin nose you do private snapchat
you could do there's a function on
Instagram where you can let specific
people see a certain story so you can
fight everyone else yeah wow I didn't
know then so you can block certain
people from seeing your stories Wow yeah
you could make some legit extra income
cat right yeah it's just your feel
that's where an aspect I'm sure a girl
what's your what's your man say about it
you'll take the photos he's like I don't
care yeah of course he will yeah I had a
girl who dancer used to dance she used
to be a stripper and we did it and she
said that she ended up dating I said he
ever date a client she goes I did once
and I said that's a lot
but let's just say you danced and I said
I didn't suck you say the guy walked in
and she goes oh he wasn't she wasn't
attracted to him he's older he's like my
age 50 something with you know yeah and
yeah kind of like I've kind of a thick
kind of dude and he said don't kept
coming back he came back like three
times and he just liked her and finally
he said so I want to I want to spend
more time with you and I don't want to
do it here she goes oh I don't do that
and he goes yeah I know he said but
what's your rent and she goes hey before
you go on yes guys named Brian Cal's
name is Brian yeah but it wasn't me so
she said that he ended up now I did he
pay her he goes he goes she's hemming I
goes I'll tell you what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna give you $15,000 a month well I am
heavy price hey I'm hiding a shade a
little not migos I'll give you a $15,000
a month and you just sucked me around
she said she goes I couldn't say no it
was so much but she took her like she's
your sister and her brother on a
vacation summer and she goes and I beak
and then I just that I love racquetball
[ __ ] but that's true she was like he
was like didn't I get married he was
undeniable do you made yep she updated
me too so undeniable
now she full of [ __ ] those great you're
not very romantic girl out scorpions
been so hot though 15 grand a month that
start lower so up to the gym I was
single and there was some smoke showing
a [ __ ] strip club and I was like dude
I will up I'd pay five grand a month
just to whatever yeah hell yeah he had
money and she was like she just lied to
you what okay you know who does that is
James Harden
because he doesn't want to get me to to
have fake rape accusations so he was
paying this
I think name was Shay us something just
this white girl with a blowout I see her
you'd pay her Jenna Shay I think you'd
pay her a monthly fee okay I'm I
endorsed it and people like dude so
she's just a professional he's at yeah I
don't give a [ __ ]
I'm endorsed that a hundred percent
that's robably
I approve let me see more pictures
please I'm gonna get my hand down my
pants this is gonna be
um yeah you would pay her and just like
he didn't have to worry about anything
she's not getting pregnant nothing she's
gonna call whenever he wanted yeah I
have a look at her look at her
yeah yeah she's thick though huh
she dick he's good yeah for sure she's
done she's done the rounds probably look
at the hips what's that say an escort
tells one NBA wife her man oh she's
talking [ __ ] to uh Dan she heard she is
bodied up a little bit of tummy on it I
don't mind that at all no she's just
Kirsch smart got hurt a little Georgia
Peach huh she will suck you dry B you
don't know dude you don't know if that's
what she's about you yes on her now
listen I'm sure I have a hunch I'm an
expert yeah she's in the black guys well
I'll tell you what I have an even bigger
that whether or not she is black guys
are very into her her DMS her Nipsey
Hussle yeah she oh he got killed didn't
he yeah is that Curt event yeah we'll
save it God hold on Ilana
my body's overloading oshi sushi is may
I see that one just that's a classy [ __ ]
though yeah I mean that's just hey can
you be a little bit more graceful you
show your [ __ ] on the bed like so I
should let me see you a few then she
farted it would be better if she farted
so that's not too obvious
no this is classy no she gets she get
his dick stay soft if he ain't got my
fee see she's she's a pearl she's a
stone-cold killer
yeah she's a traverse it stay soft if
you don't have that feet okay all right
will you payin in other words are you
paying and why do you look at um
um for sale at least she's very uh
do she screams white guys what else get
you
holy [ __ ] that is in Houston Texas -
yeah well that's that's list listen any
athletes calling all athletes in town
yeah call all athletes all over the
world yeah I bet - good time man sure
sure it's a big girl she's very sexy
yeah yeah that's how she makes her
living god bless okay Kendu your head
help me dick says she suck that's her
job
yeah I know right job listen I don't
have a problem with that though like is
that any different then I mean leash
like I don't know if she's a stripper
she might be but if she's not there's
nothing there's no difference between
stripping in that like the gig right she
just taking advantage of with social
media you don't need to be a stripper
now to get out there like she's making
Bank do ya think about it
cats a pretty girl she's getting
hundreds of dollars potentially to show
her feet if you're this curvy kitten
yeah you're this curvy snowball kid
who's very sexual you know it's money
she's getting a question we don't know
about is how does that end with with
marriage I mean it's very short so well
but short-sighted right is it is that a
crib it Jesus Christ so dope and I
should save her save your money but
here's the thing would you would you say
not that many views but here's the thing
would definitely like alligators good
luck eating her alligator but here's the
can't get his mouth around those but
here's the thing though so what she's
doing very short-sighted fresh athlete
very short-sighted that's why they're
drawn to each other ya know the UFC
fighter it's like how's this end you
better save your money
right we had a fell player house this
tent better save your money yeah
stripper houses and better save your
money yeah good job so what'd you do
yeah how's this end yeah it's been great
for you but I'm sure when you started
people said the same thing sure well you
have a stand-up is a skill set that you
can keep
forever I'm saying happening Oh actor
stand-up different yeah yeah and you
stay up - it's true man acting yeah I
know there are so many people you forget
how we're working so many but he's okay
with you like let's say this series goes
great right and then it gets picked up
another season then maybe just falls off
a bee's design into it you're back with
your back in the pool correct you're
back in the rack trying to get picked up
if that's correct that's why I'm going
on my dress yes you can stand up I know
that says you didn't have this oh you're
I mean I know guy I know too many people
that live it every day you're welcome
dude thank you I know so many people
that that that deal with that but I know
people who judge this [ __ ] out like
listen do I want her to be the mother to
my child [ __ ] no what I take her for the
Houston reside yeah yeah pay cold hard
well earned stand-up cat I have known on
occasion she's used to the improv no
judgment on it I don't have any
celebrate it's just so they all you know
what they say the oldest profession in
the world is its classes you know what
the oldest profession in the world is
you know poor that's right
prostitution is they think it's
considered the oldest profession in the
world that you know that's a say know
what though who judges this just other
women and no dudes like I can't
of course not shut the [ __ ] and and it's
always been contentious because other
women judge it because naturally they go
that girl is that she's taken my manly
my man is moonlighting on me with that
right and I get it yeah but also it'll
be a [ __ ] [ __ ] block yeah you know
don't remember this to a lot of those
women that you a lot of those women end
up when the ride ends a lot of them get
married to a dude she's hot and they
make great moms and they make great wife
and the music stops it doesn't mean that
they're all safe I got on this play may
not be the smartest person I don't know
don't hold up I bound this planet for 36
years yeah I've had my run-in with
strippers some of them are the best
people I know some more dope also some
of them are so business savvy yes it's
saying funniest few uh alumni for your
strippers cardi B think she's business
savvy huh blac Chyna mm-hmm
yeah this some of it is it's it is a
what's the word it is a type of person
typical dude I was talking to chameleon
I would give away so I'm gonna say him
where and I go dude you have a
girlfriend and he goes no not really I'm
kind of seeing this girl we just sleep
together and I go D it and I knew the
answer he's gonna listen to us I'm going
to do what the [ __ ]
and I went do you get a lot of girls and
clearly does it yes I use just hired
professionals just dead as I Skype if I
like that I appreciate that
me too congratulations and a lot less
problem look I got no problem with any
of that
none and by the way it is true that
there are plenty of strippers and plenty
of hookers quote unquote that end up
retiring and make gray wives and and
some strippers awesome people now some
of them [ __ ] mercenaries mercenaries
yes so same with dudes but again again
some fighters great do you okay some of
them if you're still up I knew a girl I
knew a girl who was a straight up
working girl okay in Venice pasta - yes
and she said to me I interviewed her for
a [ __ ] TV show
no and I said to her I said what is it
that guy she goes well I remember I was
so poor my mother worked in a in a
slaughterhouse
and then she worked as a waitress in
this in this podunk diner it was the
only diner around we were and they lived
in Howard Johnson's and in motels and
she would take the coins she made from
tips and they would put him out on the
bed and they could they would divvy out
to see what kind of food they could get
and whether or not they could eat
chicken or meat that when you grew up
that [ __ ] poor yeah you will never be
broke again oh and then you're really
pretty
and you're and men are looking at you
and they'll give you if you've never
seen more than you've never seen more
than a thought you never see more than
five hundred dollars in your life in one
place and the guy goes I'll give you 500
bucks to suck my dick
whitey whatever it might be something
listen for some rumors she's making
millions of dollars maybe so these girls
charge what three grand them an evening
or whatever
four grand I don't know no worth it cute
doggies pitbulls are black guys what's
wrong with that
mm-hmm
yeah yeah like peanut butter and jelly
baby topic I'm not mad at her I don't
know how we uh started on this uh oh we
were talking about shoes no how I he's
got a girl I don't remember I don't
either
I think it's coffee shop girls oh yeah
coffee shop girls yeah cool man
oh no you're saying what's his name he
had he hired a girl cuz didn't want to
get me too all you want to get me too so
you know makes sense yeah I'll do the
exact same thing about ya yep oh yeah no
problem with it mm-hmm Kat you can make
some legit money even guys are my show
dude you just show cat more man like put
your dick in your pants okay let's relax
that's right do you need to put a camera
on chat on cat man yeah and then they
combine the two and called you chat have
a chat can you know what hung out with
this weekend and had a great time and
her boyfriend Kyle cat Katelyn she's
number three flyweight in the world
Katelyn um how's her last name what's in
it yeah yeah yeah she kidding yeah
really greeny a picture but really cool
human be her and her boyfriend Kyle I
[ __ ] had a blast with them came to my
show and they were just awesome number
three flyweight oh yeah she's stud yeah
stud stud yeah awesome I was talking
about boxing III just tell the story and
she goes she look amazing cuz she were
always kind of drinking we had had a
great time as she goes I'd beat your ass
she wears his [ __ ] around and then we
started like most she just closed it I
was like oh Jesus Christ
yeah it was a [ __ ] yeah and so brown
belt yeah enjoy that enjoy that if your
guy like me hey did you are you went to
school at American uh yes I did is that
in DC it is in DC I went there for four
years lived on Massachusetts Avenue and
then Wisconsin Avenue I believe God what
a great town yeah not when I was it was
a great town but not like the bit is now
when I was there it's different in the
eighties it's a different bird yeah you
want very dangerous you have to Calgary
this week I'm off to Calgary this week
agrees like Denver but not as cool right
reminds me a lot of Denver but not as
crowded yeah well it's an oil town there
was a lot of money now with the oil
prices and stuff if you
today you know who's the president of
that [ __ ] town Bret the Hitman Hart
bro watch your P's and Q's no yeah
give me my showing sweats what you
staring J soul they put you a nice hotel
there yeah that way you should do not
wonder I know where they say yeah that
one's really nice um the Calgary has
always been a fun time for me I probably
might [ __ ] 8th time going back yep and
then I go to oh I'm going alone start
what is that casino I'm going to the one
in Albuquerque New Mexico oh that's the
one I did I told you to get brooming
yeah it's a good room right here's the
prettiest you know anything casino
here's the edge in general casino shows
are awful but they're the worst but this
one in Santa Ana stark santa ana star
here's the reason why 12 13 4 it's a
route it's an actual like it's not like
you're not weird like ballroom it's an
act it's just made for comedy it is oh
good I think tell me it was a great room
like it originated a schwoz do you like
DJs in the club okay but it feels like
almost like a little mini theatre okay
like it's doing edge yeah great room the
stage at the star is called the stage
extra you don't think you do I know they
listen the podcast
they just need to market it better they
need to mark it as a comedy plate right
ditch the [ __ ] look at it it's sick
ditch the club vibe ditch the DJs they
could pack it there was cooking me
really all right I'm excited man damn no
you're gonna bomb it's not a big deal
yeah that's good I know I always palm
it's the one thing I'm looking forward
to it santa ana star casino April 12 and
13 on TV I'm seeing a really good food
dude you go outside and Albuquerque has
amazing coffee and food so I'm gonna be
in Albuquerque basically you're not a
team you're literally like a mile
outside of it oh wow okay perfect I
spent I did a TV show there for two
years so I'll go train to Jackson's I'll
go do some sparring
do that man I'll walk in with my mouth
gear is there anybody I can spar uh yeah
Jon Jones be there let me know that goes
for you I'm gonna spar everybody that I
don't give a [ __ ] spar Diego Sanchez
that's huh hey can I want to go five
rounds with Diego is he around no one
move around with Carlos Condit is around
this case I wish hey if you're if you're
at
Jaxon's come come to the shower you
[ __ ] early [ __ ] I don't know I
just I'm kind of aggressive with MMA
guys some of my favorite fighters in
that [ __ ] gym I want to go bomb to go
say I know Greg so I guess I had how bad
do you love to you notice that these
gyms that's where you'll buy know what I
mean but I was it was fun I've never I
don't do go to gyms usually but a top
team it was cool they're like a weird
you know this field hole this timeless
gather anything anymore whatever John
Johnny Jones weird I guess if they've
ever come through they put him on there
it's cool though
yep cool yeah tomorrow night I won't be
I supposed to do that show with you at
the Comedy Store and I've supposed to
show him I do want to show it the
comment here at this comedy story I
think to 10:30 it's a mellow show the
main room 10:30 then I supposed to do
that now they're not supposed to show at
the Laugh Factory Thalia but tomorrow
I'm shooting the opening of my comedy
special we have like this whole funny
opening and we start shooting at one and
don't rap to midnight so that's
fantastic well and I just found out so
I'm excited laughter I didn't know I was
doing stand-up tomorrow night thank you
I'm pretty sure you are yeah Bob was
possibly on it yeah
really no you don't mellow yeah Sarah I
love yes sir oh wait let me see if I am
pay attention these things you're best
off to go then through their Instagram
chin I'm doing I'm doing the glam
factory Wednesday night yeah I got a P
go piss bro I piss hard too let's go P
you want to go P secure my hips well
they're just fart bottom second row
top left sake you're wrote that one yep
there I am
there you are still great show Sarah
Silverman cool I know I love Silverman I
was looking for an out Rawlings all
those [ __ ] Michael Yost I mean
go ahead I'm gonna go pee alright let's
do some current events buddy what do you
think I quit
right April Fool's ah man you scared the
[ __ ] out of me Brennan you're fired uh
uh he just dropped everything April
Fool's oh [ __ ] now he just put his pants
and good thing he wears diapers man
diapers
cheaper TV work did that to us one time
his head fit this is really hot girls
like 33 whatever right how was it [ __ ]
i what because it's just don't say
anything I know my thing is she wore
diapers
a lot it there he was bullshitting yes
she shat and yeah terrible story all
right what do we got
so Elon Musk released a song called
r.i.p Harambee it's a joke right this is
an April Fool's joke this was released I
believe a day ago or she's really
rapping no it's not him who is Harambee
did someone jack is social media
know that he posted this up I think he
paid someone to make it Harambee is the
girl of they shot yeah where'd the
little kid fell in the encampment shock
it's not bad to see own emoji records or
something I'm not sure
[Music]
I just I'm just confused and so is it's
not terrible song but I'm just I'm just
confused why Elon Musk would i limp let
this might be my finest work is he
someone have his children hostage and
was like you better blast my [ __ ] rap
video out I'm gonna kill these days but
a lot of people are confused on why he
created this song and released it but
but he didn't yet sing it
no I'm him sounds like a lil yachty song
weird very strange yeah yeah well
strange dude yeah okay so a study found
that drunk shoppers spend on average
four hundred and forty four dollars on
online shopping when they're tipsy which
amounts to forty eight billion dollars
per year in a dog the kated shopping
holy [ __ ] just uh wow I mean I'm not
gonna lie yeah pretty tipsy my second
show on Saturday night went back to the
room my brother was also a little tipsy
off whiskey maybe is hey I've seen this
new collab that Todd Snider did with
champion like no bring it up he brings
it up we were in a bunch of [ __ ] now I'm
looking back I'm like oh [ __ ] I forgot
we did that Wow
damn sometimes you just get just get
that you just like ah it's like helps
you spur the moment yeah yeah I would
imagine cocaine would do that but not
alcohol no cocaine I don't think you
want to stop and like put in the info
and [ __ ] you just got to move Mack and
cocaine yeah weed maybe that makes sense
the vicious cycle you ever you don't
really drink right yeah no I don't drink
ever
mmm very very rarely chin you ever
ordered [ __ ] drunk yeah yeah it's just
fun to do two ounces really casually
I do fun to do my fishing stuff all I do
sometimes if I'm on a plane if I think
something my order if I have Wi-Fi or do
some weird [ __ ] if it's late at night
I'll do it all we could make some I
can't the final need that I ordered
shiny boots randomly that's I just
remember rally that's boots I guess
they're dress boots they're like Doc
Martens but they're shiny I didn't I
normally wouldn't buy shiny boots into
the black and shiny and your chambray
tall is drunk yeah we're not drunk by
yourself by yourself by myself you
should you drink by yourself no we went
out to drink oh all right
yeah shiny boots what else we got but I
do drink by myself sometimes the thrall
dad dude all right all right said next
point okay so a man that works at an
enterprise
I believe in Missouri laced his
co-workers of water with LSD and he says
that it's because they were killing the
vibes he said he thinks they're negative
that is [ __ ] hilarious and so the man
who works of that yes the manager of
that enterprise noticed that some of the
workers were acting kind of odd and two
of them fell sick and so they went to
the hospital got checked out and they
realized that they had been drugged with
Ella how did they find out was that gay
cuz he gave him like lemonade or so he
admitted it oh he's like my bad
yeah that's remarks gonna increase the
morale around here I wonder if they sold
more cars though like did they do work
no I mean he's a rental car place they
usually go reservation Oh
how many numbers do they type in in when
they I can actually do if you need a
rav4 we have those this is my favorite I
want that we have a tart charger for a
little more hustle for insurance fully
covered it's really gonna be next your
$49.99 per day right when your credit
card does cover that you want the gas
option great oh I would I always do the
gas option I would do it because I'm too
lazy you ever you know you know you're
lazy when even it's on E and I'm closing
like I'm not stop and charge me whatever
you want right [ __ ] you that's right
I don't have the energy I'm poor is
there anything worse no you know what Jo
a shuttle to a car we are another
yeah you still rent cars yeah that's
unbelievable to me with uber these days
I just the business like yeah I want to
what else is crazy dude yeah that I need
a car
good I'm like waiting on her who else we
got so there's a hashtag going around
that's hashtag surviving cardi B and
that's because a video that she posted
on Instagram live was posted from three
years ago every surface and it was her
crying complaining about how people said
that her fame was given to her and so
she was saying that she had to do
terrible things in the past yes is her
mug right she's a book coming she's
writing a book and I think that that's
included yeah in the book she says
before she had did you know she was a
high-end stripper she would drug the
guys right she would be drunk gosh she's
you would want to [ __ ] her after she's
done stripping wait what'd you say so
she would take certain guys back to
hotel rooms after she's done stripping
because they wanted to [ __ ] her yeah and
she would drugged them and then rob them
however she came out in a later
statement saying that it was consensual
and those guys were I guess dating her
so it's kind of weird I seem like she
backed rash so she put I had to go strip
out to go oh yeah you want to [ __ ] me
yeah let's go back to this to the to
this hotel and i drugged those ninjas up
and I robbed them that's what I used to
do I mean people have done things like
that because I never claimed to be an
angel I've always been a street [ __ ]
she's be horrifying these streets
rappers this talk and do grimy [ __ ] but
they can't stand a street [ __ ] I mean
for me it's like she's just telling it
how she is and she's not that any more
rape my friend my friend [ __ ] I used
to work with at Lehman Brothers can't be
good he he [ __ ] that this girl goes
I'll blow you and she took him in his
car and blew him she pulled his pants
down to blow into winter but yeah she
pulled his pants all the way down she
socked them off in the pastures he pulls
him back she took his wallet and all his
money in this guy yeah game he played
that's her issue you away that's all and
then she jumped out and got in a cab he
was like my wallet everything yeah so
you did cost you a lot more you hired
professional 50 bucks
took a few I'll do a better job
protecting your wallets right happens
all the time you know it's just behind I
like I kind of like I mean cardies she
had a past yeah she seemed to also like
she was apologetic for but she was at
raping them right she wasn't I still
like sucking them off while her passed
down drug in the Raza that she would
drug them and then robbed them if you
want to sing for them
yeah that that would be there would be a
serious crime that's called grand
larceny and a lot of other things I
think but I would assume there's even a
lawsuit like some dumbass oh my god I
hooked up with her it with no proof for
this case you good luck with that I mean
it is what it is she's I'm a big fan
yeah
drug me up girl she did that thought and
she still worked at that strip club when
they come back and probably not know
what are you gonna do [ __ ] with the
bouncers and those strip clubs could ya
good good luck does she she's like the
butterfly yeah and if you choose a
gangster it's gonna be different but I'm
like a gangster I don't know I feel like
you call the head [ __ ] at a strip club
the butterfly she's like the the
flashiest one and everybody else is a
caterpillar sure it's Madame Butterfly
qu they view the queen butterfly no
one's [ __ ] with me man mm-hmm she was
definitely the queen butterfly yeah she
had all those other girls on lockdown
money the only problem is if you're a
husband you're like okay she's all yeah
I staked him boy Elmo said I was taking
boys back and [ __ ] them no person would
have any judgment on yeah I mean either
she's hard well I think around this time
she was a date dating a dude who is
actually in prison for a couple years
yeah hip hop she go to prison like you
better not be [ __ ] nobody
it was great she said that she wouldn't
[ __ ] any dudes but she would [ __ ] other
girls so it didn't count
she is delicious she's a character well
I bet she made Bank
she's a personality man mm-hmm super
talented her sisters bad too today oh
yeah look at the peacock tattoo I
celebrate that is that quite a big yes
sir
making money Jesus gee-whiz all right
why not
let us get so NASA had a all-female
spacewalk in the works and it got
canceled last minute because they didn't
have a spacesuit that would fit one of
the women so there are supposed to be
two women who went and both women needed
a size medium but there was only one
suit that was in that size and it would
take I think a couple years and like
millions of dollars to create shoes and
rather than saying that they're gonna
put off the project until they have that
spacesuit ready they just cancelled it
Wow
they said [ __ ] it yeah and a lot of
people are shoes for women yeah a lot of
people are angry about why don't you
make another one but they don't know
that it would take years and millions
and millions of dollars to me oh you
mean they're not space they're
astrophysicists it seemed like NASA shot
themselves in the foot by announcing it
before they were prepared God here we go
we put a man on the moon but we can't
find a space suit that fits a woman by
Friday and then Hillary Clinton
retweeted or tweeted make another suit
hey thanks shut your [ __ ] mouth yeah
thanks Hillary we'll do that we'll get
right on that because that easy don't
you think they want this you think NASA
wants this backlash I'll think that wow
I'm sooo gonna make beyond the a we have
that much money sexism in the space
program it's not sexism shut the [ __ ] up
but also what were unit what were they
gonna do what were they gonna do what
are they planning to do up there
yeah just research research make sure
your vagina's representives which are a
battery for something and are the trends
and the trans and dwarves and we need
more people are there any black people
in the H in crime there's no Korean for
the clothes and the Vietnamese come on
man we gotta have everybody's
everybody's gotta be represented let's
make you know suits for dwarves it's
gonna take a while i won it's a reach I
don't want just vaginas up there but
also you just switching our batteries
who cares but who gives a funny you mean
you don't care that it's a guy with a
dick over a girl listen man we have to
have a representation an equal
representation of
ovaries I don't care if you sent Charles
Manson up to switch out the batteries
just get it done let's just dummies why
doesn't that have to work faster us oh
my god can't believe that just came up
well do we really need to know I mean
[Music]
there are limitations here yeah let's be
real stuff kind of a suit to fit over
that ass do you know what I'm going man
Doris have badasses in the best thing
possible
don't try to pack track that no I'm
serious don't say and they all have a
thing possible that is the best way
possible but you panicked a little bit
that's awesome and the dwarf lobby's
coming after you I'm going to help them
and I'll be right there picking who Yuri
their leaves taller than all of them but
still be like the way back what else we
got
a bit of sad news that guy that rapper
Nipsey Hussle was murdered yesterday
inside of a store in LA right in LA
during the dead apparently he's like a
huge lie that like tries to put LA up
here's thing here's a money there shame
to live in Calabasas lower the [ __ ] you
want we want to stick around and vest
back in the community I refused to leave
and his fiancee her girlfriend was
gorgeous that's how I knew who he was he
so pretty Lauren London
she's so me what happened what happened
again related they're saying it's gang
related but a lot of people who live in
the communities says that that's just
what the media is saying and that his
gang affiliations are aren't really as
strong as they were when he first
started rapping but what's weird is he
tweet out right before he died
nothing better than a strong enemy and
they get shot like an hour later a lot
of people think it's a conspiracy based
off of the documentary that he's in the
problem he was in the process of making
it's about a doctor who found like a
holistic approach to curing HIV and AIDS
he did come out in an interview a couple
months ago saying that he was going to
promote that project coming out and that
if they killed whoever they are kills
him then he wants all of his fans to
ride hard for him yeah so they think the
media just said it's a gang really yeah
if you had to put money
yeah I see it's getting affiliated with
me too it still sucks but shot in broad
daylight
yeah o'clock he understood he has a
store and they're doing like a NAT grand
opening or something I think let me see
the video everybody the video sucks do I
see the one where they yeah then it's
it's hard to see but you can see him
fall down after being shot the guy just
rolls up to him right yeah you look in
this area here you'll see a bunch of
stuff happening it's the only video we
got yeah that's all they have for now
and they had the ambulance one which
sucks worse see right now they're
running and then that's where you got
shot and fell down damn he shot him
point-blank
they said he shot him six times times
yeah buddy see boom this guy's running
this way and he went into a car with a
female driver which is weird too
disgusting man and this is just a very
sad video of them trying to revive him
so just go ah dammit that's funny don't
see terrible man that's [ __ ] awful
yeah that's [ __ ] terrible God boys he
33 mm-hmm really yeah that's awful man
and his he was up for album of the year
mm-hmm Usami for grammar Grammy yeah as
a daughter
think your daughter ha ha
a lot of people are trying to get the
word out that he actually owned all of
the masters two songs into stream his
album so all that money would then go to
his daughter you know what I'm so
heartbreak that's so awful man it's so
heartbreaking
he's [ __ ] what else we good Chris
Rock making a joke all this was because
I see this now but I love it double and
and double is home not to me they fell
not to watch this yeah
this is great
[Music]
an award they said no jussie Smollett
jokes yeah no I know what a waste of
light-skinned you know you don't have to
do it that light-skinned that curly hair
my gorillas beat oh yeah
[ __ ] run in Hollywood
yes no no no just I never know just your
Jessie from now on you can get the you
know mom that you is respect you like
getting no respect from me okay Image
Award goes to bad so this show they were
there defending Jessie small F you know
Anthony Anderson yeah I was really
surprised the arm say that he defended
Jessie's I stand with Jessie we don't
integrate we recreate that's another
part let's know their stand with Jessie
really what's his stand for Wow stupid
you stand with that guy you know you're
bad that makes them look by doing that
Wow being seen see what happens to their
rate that's offensive to black people
that's what I'm saying you know you were
reduced and you took advantage of all
this [ __ ] when it never happened to you
huh and the prosecutors say that he he's
not innocent that's just the easiest way
to deal with this like correct yeah I
mean that's the worst Punisher he would
get anyways he actually did some
interviews like outside when he was
walking and they announced that the
charges were dropped saying I maintained
my innocence oh he started taking photos
of fans he's the one man that guy I
can't stand either yeah yeah yeah
there's an Illinois legislature that's
trying to put in a bill I guess if you
film in a in a state like you get tax
breaks alright so they're saying anyone
who employs Jesse small that they're
well that's they're not gonna get the
tax big he's actually gonna put the bill
into place [ __ ] dumb bill but well I
feel like you have better bills to pass
yeah whatever
let's go after one dumbass he's a
[ __ ] more I don't know anyone who's
gonna hire him anyway but I'm curious to
see if he gets hired again you know I'm
spinning the black beans you know
support Mia yeah you think something a
bit Tyler Perry makes an entire movie
about him
Wow huh
that'll be shocked I'll be tough I
wouldn't you know that's less about him
and more about [ __ ] you to the system
and this is happening you know it hurts
you more that you put him in a movie
just yeah it separates people even more
yeah doing really old stupid thing he's
a bad guy did a bad thing
well these guys I think he's a [ __ ]
idiot he's he's a better assistant at
yeah all these bad per I do
I think nice things in our sis and I
think he thought it would get him
attention but I don't think he meant to
hurt anyone I don't think he thought you
I think it was the most divisive thing
in the world you thought he meant to
hurt people yes I think what he's trying
to do well regards I don't think he
cared I think what he's doing is think
about what he did he said that that
Chicago first of all he had all those
cops working on a case
he said Chicago I was attacked by white
guy don't worry magog that's why there
you go so what if I testified against
someone that was you know right yeah
you're right and so I see I don't think
he thought I was gonna escalate to this
point yeah yeah he is hurting those yeah
he definitely is not a very smart guy
you don't think ahead oh you got to be a
moaner she said yeah you right baby
there yeah dive dive dive dummy [ __ ]
that guy yom-yom me know she had gin all
right this isn't that new but this is
Kobe Bryant remember when um LeBron
James did that one interview with his
buddies his show he's like he calls
himself the greatest of all time so this
is Kobe Bryant on James Corden's show
James Corbin right Gordon Gordon James
Corden show and then they kinda asked
him a question like who was the top
three him and did he have an answer he
had an answer eat a cow Tom doesn't say
he goes when they ever ask him with
Jordan they're always like you know you
don't rank yourself like yeah they tell
you who's the greatest it's more like a
I think it's more joking let's see okay
yes I would like you to rank these
legendary basketball players from best
to worst
good job Michael Jordan and Kobe Bryant
that's hilarious
he does the best job making viral videos
that's why he might be the most relevant
in late lunch such as tuck into that cow
tongue baby you know what I'm gonna
answer but I'm not going to answer it
cuz it everybody's gonna sit there and
debate about it so I'm just gonna take a
bite of it oh my god that's disgusting
[Music]
pretty straightforward I think Michaels
second-best ago
[ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm Jabez what gay but you start
clapping of course you see him still
like this and you oh [ __ ] look at my hey
Jesse smaller like this yeah oh sweet
first time you realize I'm actually gay
in my shows every [ __ ] time there's
some to do join big girl yeah no [ __ ]
guy stuff like that yeah I was clapping
it's your ballgame don't use your
fingers no if you clap like a seal yeah
I just touched my palms I'll just seal
no strange yeah that looked very on
aesthetic my knees knock yeah that's
very good what else yet you guys big
Bill & Ted's Excellent I don't know who
they are old old
okay well Keanu Reeves he's actually
gonna reprise that role they're making a
third don't want to see that
I feel like Keanu Reeves is so much
about it so much that's what's amazing
about this is the trailer right no
they're just announcing it's called
facing music and they're by the
Hollywood Bowl damn least uh bills aged
well look man
go hit play look I'm Alex winter and I'm
Keanu Reeves and together we are wild
stallions and we are here at the
Hollywood Bowl where we'll never play
never play
oh well we're here to announce something
yes we want to say thank you to you the
fans we do because it looks like we
might actually hopefully make a movie
this summer bill in Ted three face the
music yes and it is all because of you
guys and so we owe you huge dude he
looks like Larry Bird's nuts on the
level ever bet she'll be funny and she's
the first to know so how do you don't
see me funny
there are fifty years old now and step
older than that I think franchise you
know I find that embarrassing it's weird
right yeah gonorrhea soonest Keanu
Reeves looks awesome
that other guy looks I mean that is
tough and kena's tall about 60 I was
surprised talk at maybe in taller Jana
yeah I think he's about six three
Jolly's I mean printing money yeah
the John wick [ __ ] the matron makes
some money
oh my god he's going so motorcycle
company yeah there no money problems for
sure Kim God laugh is so happy the
regular fiance he owns a [ __ ]
motorcycle come here I don't know yep
what's it called
I forget yeah he's super into
motorcycles yeah he bought like I think
he bought all the stuntmen motorcycles
well you know gave it to him candy owns
a company yeah
arch I forget he owns it with it's
pretty cool I can't believe they're
making that movie yeah you never saw
Bill and Ted be sure didn't certain
things I just did it's been even more
embarrassing when they really could you
they act like whoa dude like surfers
like surfer like I want to get a
motorcycle I mean I don't ride them no
I'm afraid just ride around the block
you too old if you haven't done it yet
you know it's pretty not happening on
yeah I wish I had one
well I want to sketch it I can't believe
to make that movie alright the other
ones just not that great but it's the
last one
Disneyland's gonna ban smoking and big
strollers and ice cubes
when ice cubes it says something it says
like the dry ice stuff people throw them
Oh dries Hungary when the parents bring
them in
yeah it takes longer to check I guess
big strollers make sense either because
I can't get him through or something or
you can't get around them they take up
so much room like this
that'll help up the double strollers in
other words I think the double if
they're shot you can get the like this
but when they're parallel they're a
night it stops traffic yeah okay but
smoking you know you seem like a bunch
of different smoking stations it is very
rare less these people swimming oh my
god I see it all the time I really my
friends would do it there which is I
promise idiot maybe this Milwaukee but
people were smoking like in the bars and
[ __ ] yeah wow that's so old school who
smokes in 2019 I know he'll just I
remember when they went really I don't
want to stop smoking when they said you
weren't a lot smoke in bars and it was a
huge uproar that what the love the
government's teach you tell me what to
do and the oh my god so bad it's also
like but I'll say being in as a comic
when I used to work when I started you
could smoke single Club oh yeah think
about it
oh you B you'd be doing stand-up and
people would be smoking and you'd be
inhaling that all and you would get
dizzy secondhand smoke you'd let you get
[ __ ] so dizzy and and I always forget
that I remember I remember and then I'm
her they banned it and then I went to
like Kansas City or somewhere like that
where they still smoked and I remember
getting [ __ ] dizzy because people
were smoking in the Plus remember you
see it's weird that we'd be smoking now
but secondhand smoke is real it's so
strange what my grandma it's mo complain
remember there was a smiling grandma
grandpa you smoked like chimneys my
grandpa actually died from it they both
died from it but I married we'd go over
the house we'd go over there all the
time they'd smoke so much obviously I
get sick and smoke that's fantastic the
other thing is it ruined your clothes oh
yeah your clothes yeah but I mean planes
on a tube you do it anywhere dude
smoking session I'll be in the
non-smoking oh my god it's weird thing
about the smoke is not smoking a lot of
people were like the government should
me tell me what to do I'm like no except
for your smoke is so causing problems
for children you'd have a baby there
that's movie theaters I don't remember
yeah you can usually like open law yeah
you could smoke everyone now it's I mean
now you're not outdoor malls in
California can't smoke there's nowhere
for me smart smoke so we thank God
set it Jim that's it's cool man kids OH
come see me in Calgary but I think we're
sold out I think there might be some
tickets left for the Thursday show New
Mexico
April 12 13 I'm gonna be at the stage at
santa ana star casino right outside
Albuquerque come see me kids come see me
I'm excited oh now where am I after that
can I see yeah sorry um I got Miami May
900 de Young nerves hit dammit we
already sold out a Saturday I think so
Denver uh April 25 26 27 come see me
this Friday I'm at the ice house with
Joe Rogan and Derek post in two shows
Friday I think it's a 8 and 10 o'clock
you have to check but it's this Friday I
think the first shows already sold out
get tickets right now I saw Joe Rogan
Derek Poston and then after that end of
the month I'm at stand-up live in
Phoenix
then it's Phoenix Arizona that is April
26th 27th so that is two shows Friday to
show Saturday Phoenix stand-up live
after that I'm in San Antonio Texas to
trick you that tea fat cake on for Bryan
myself that's it this is the fun kid
we're out yeah